on vit dans ton bouquin tu voudrais
faire un talk show à 23 heures ça
m'inquiète ça alors j'ai dit que le
c'est vrai que le talk show est une
quand on a fait de la radio
quotidiennement de la télévision façon
mensuelle ou hebdomadaire on a envie
inquiète on en bouleau par non mais une
maquette page cap à cet effet et je suis
dit j'aimerais bien un jour faire ça
mais c'est totalement incompatible est
ce que je fais actuellement et je ne
suis pas certain qu un directeur de
chaîne sur l'intéressé par ceux projetés
bas sinon il ya un truc est très
étonnant c'est que tu dis que si tu
étais sépharade suspect sur la
surrelance un coup sûr la une mais comme
thq nas est resté sur le banc quand même
90 par icloud c'est une image mais on va
bien dans mes génies que c'est vrai que
que dans notre métier
en général dans le monde du spectacle
les juifs d'afrique d'origine d'afrique
du nord on les trouve davantage du côté
d'ea me disant financier oui on les
trouve plus du côté du mieux disant
financier réclamé les augures et voilà
mais c'était une boutade d'accord est
sûre tu fais un petit reproche parce que
lors des niveaux il faut quand on lis tu
dis je vais dire des choses que j'ai
jamais dit etc
et puis finalement quand on dit de nous
quand je me demande si tu es vraiment
passer de l'autre côté du miroir parce
que apparente que tu fume la pipe le
week-end qu'est ce qu'on apprend
vraiment concerné pas je veux dire c'est
ma maman mais je ne sais pas qu'elle n'a
pas voulu gagner trop d'argent en allant
sur l'annoncé que j'ai pas voulu
voilà c'est gentil oui mais je crois pas
être en servant les chocs non je pense
pas que tu soit franchement je pense pas
qu'elle ait pu dire des choses un peu
plus je sais pas s'il sera continue donc
la femme en disant je sais pas est déjà
en avoir je suis pas c'est selon moi il
ya des jours où elle du mal à supporter
ouais mais men en jeu j'ai pas mon
histoire et d'une finalement une grande
banalité
ouais moi c'est plutôt télé télétravail
boulot que j'adore sages aucun mérite
mais
je commence déjà à faire de très gros
progrès puisque pour la première fois
grâce à toi je viens aux bains douches
jacques tu vois et j'ai mis une demi
heure avant de trouver mais tu peux
revenir chez bram était le bienvenu tu
rencontreras mort aussi